99 foi o ano que eu entrei na faculdade
foi um ano que eu resolvi fazer te tura
e esse é um ano que mudou minha vida não
só porque foi um ano que eu escolhi
entrar na faculdade mas porque foi o ano
que eu entrei em contato pela primeira
vez com as tecnologias digitais
foi minha primeira conta de email foram
as minhas primeiras redes sociais quem
se lembrar na psiquê e aquilo mudou
completamente a minha visão de mundo né
eu entendi que comecei a entender que
daqui pra frente a gente a ficar cada
vez mais conectado é que as distâncias
estavam ficando menores entende também
que a arquitetura e design eles não
podiam mais ser feito somente de matéria
física é de de coisas que a gente pode
tocar mas que tinha uma virtualidade que
estava se misturando nosso o nosso mundo
eu acredito que a gente é parte de uma
geração muito muito importante na
história da humanidade nós somos a única
geração na história da humanidade
inteira que nasce em ambiente analógico
e assistir a transição promete digital
para pensar nisso é teoricamente isso
nos faz bastante especiais nem a gente
tem aí talvez um senso crítico a gente
está vendo algo que ninguém viu do mundo
analógico por um digital todas as
próximas gerações já nascem nesse mundo
digital está nas nossas mãos
lidar com essas tecnologias eu acho
fascinante
tem outra coisa que eu acho muito
estimulante que entender que nós somos a
primeira geração de cyborgs quando a
gente fala de ciborgue ver logo aquele
imaginário hollywoodiano robocop o amigo
robô é um pouco isso mas não é bem isso
na verdade porque nós somos a primeira
geração de cyborgs isso é fato
de um lado porque o homem está ficando
cada vez mais tecnológico cada vez mais
uma químico né
a gente está se misturando com as
tecnologias o nosso corpo físico nós
colocando está se misturando com as
tecnologias
somos uma geração protege
dica é a gente utiliza próteses que
corrigem o nosso o nosso organismo algum
defeito alguma falha que ampliam a nossa
nosso senso de humanidade uma perna
mecânica corrigir um acidente por
exemplo uma capaz
o olho biônico são próteses o submarino
uma prótese ela leva o nosso corpo
profundo do oceano onde a gente não
conseguiria ir nadando
o telescópio leva o nosso olhar para as
estrelas é maravilhoso o microscópio
levo meu olho pra dentro do próprio
organismo para dentro das células com
maravilhoso é isso então de um lado esse
homem máquina e pico
do outro a tecnologia ficando cada vez
mais humanizada ficando mais amigável
está ficando mais fácil lidar com elas
eu eu tenho certeza que os nossos netos
os nossos filhos ele não dá muita risada
quando eles souberem que a gente
acessava neoci belo espaço por esse
computador pré-histórico a gente ainda
está na pré história da tecnologia né é
um teclado e uma tela bidimensional e
vou fazer xixi na calça que ele soubesse
que era assim que a gente acessava o
ciber espaço então as tecnologias estão
começando cada vez mais a ler o nosso
corpo a lei a nossa subjetividade
digamos assim tem tem milhões de
interface sendo desenvolvidas que
reconhecem o meu batimento cardíaco as
ondas cerebrais minha posição no espaço
e interfaces que através da análise do
meu rosto sabe reconhecer seu tento seu
tom irritado se eu to feliz se eu tô
triste
bom o homem máquina cgu ea máquina
humanizada é dessa mistura que surge
essa geração se bode e daí sai
nanotecnologia biotecnologia clonagem
genoma não dá a gente não quiser ficar
com medo e acho que nem deslumbre né
acho que nem diabo eo anjo é um fato é
uma realidade o mundo mudou o mundo está
mudando como a gente vai lidar com o
mundo a grande questão
eu acho que é fundamental também
perceber eu acho incrível que a
realidade é outra e eu acho que a gente
vive uma realidade misturado uma
realidade brita o mundo físico
adicionado desse mundo digital
essas são questões que têm inspirado
bastante o meu o meu trabalho dentro do
estúdio ea gente tem experimentado na
quando eu terminei o o homem a graduação
eu ingressei no mestrado e finalmente
ver aquela crise na playboy agora é
continuar a cadeira que estava adorando
da aula estava adorando o universo
acadêmico ou será que eu vou para uma
pra pra pôr a mão na massa e me fascinou
perceber que a nossa humanidade nessa
questão da cultura cyborg está ampliando
nesta mudando a nossa maneira de se
relacionar com o mundo e está mudando
nossa subjetividade não existe uma outra
maneira de receber essas informações
somos uma geração que liga diferente com
essa tecnologia que liga diferente em
sociedade tem uma outra cognição mesmo
tem outra maneira de lidar
eu falei bom vamos colocar a mão na
massa e vamos ver o que dá para fazer
com isso então recentemente no estúdio
de uns anos pra cá a gente tem tentado
experimentar essas tecnologias digitais
seja o objeto seja em cenografia sem
espaços mais recentemente a gente
começou a fazer arquitetura que vão
construir prédios de são paulo
trabalhando com essa possibilidade de
imaginar um mundo mais interativo mais
compartilhado mas emotivo é eu gosto
muito de imaginar que é possível esculpe
algo que é inatingível na intransitável
na verdade
desculpe memórias não é como eu gosto de
definir o que a gente tem feito o ovo
projeto que vai passar a qualquer
momento
love foi um foi um projeto que eu assino
junto com a de 3 e ele parte de uma
observação que o que veio um dia no
insight é o seguinte quando a gente está
amando quando a gente tá nervoso quando
a gente está ansioso o nosso corpo
produz reações físicas né o nosso
coração dispara a nossa atenção muda eu
sou mais minha voz fica trêmula
bom meu corpo produz dados físicos dados
emocionais e esse agente coletasse esses
dados para construir design então 9 o
que a gente fez a gente
é convidar pessoas a narrar em as suas
maiores histórias de amor é isso que eu
peço pra elas
a gente coloca as pessoas no ambiente
isolado não me interessa a história em
si me interessa os estados emocionais
então quando a gente começa a gravar as
histórias a gente não a gente não gravar
o áudio ninguém fica na sala ouvindo som
que a gente faz o esse projeto acontecer
a gente usou a gente estuda uma série de
sensores
isso também é é muito interessante o
sensor estão ficando mais baratos
acessíveis essa tecnologia está cada vez
mais próxima da gente a gente escolheu
três sensores para trabalhar nesse
projeto
um deles é o sensor de batimento
cardíaco o outro um sensor que mede a
atividade cerebral e outro é a voz então
a partir desses três dados quando eles
estão contando as histórias de amor a
gente coleta desses dados que a gente
fez a gente construiu uma interface que
analisa esses dados que lei esses dados
e que cria objetos
bom essa interface funcionando como é
que a gente faz então o primeiro tem que
escolher qualquer objeto que quer gerar
por exemplo um vaso uma luminária uma
fruteira
quando você escolhe esse objeto na
verdade que você está escolhendo a um
campo de gravidade
eu chamo de princípio das partículas não
foi foi a maneira que a gente encontrou
para desenhar sua interface as
partículas elas surgem do meio vão sendo
desenhadas na verdade elas são atraídas
para esse campo de gravidade um cada um
desses sensores responde a uma a um
comportamento dessas partículas então a
voz que é coletada pelo sensor
ela altera a velocidade que essas
partículas andam o batimento cardíaco
ele altera diretamente na espessura
dessa partícula é como se a gente
pudesse tocar o batimento cardíaco na
peça ea o sensor que mede a atividade
cerebral ele atua diretamente na atração
e repulsão entre partículas então a
regra do jogo é a mesma só que o
resultado é inesperado
aquela primeira foi a dona iraci ela
gerou uma fruteira ao me contar
o amor que ela tem pelas três filhas
essa segunda imagem do felipe
ele narrou o amor que ele tem pelo
sobrinho dele ea gente criou uma
luminária e a próxima história é da laís
ela narrou ela descobriu a família dela
descobriu uma carta de amor que o avô
tinha deixado pela avó ia lá e ela é
descreve a emoção ao essa carta é bom
quando a gente cria esse objeto o que a
gente faz depois a mandar esse arquivo
para uma impressora 3d
a gente sabe que há a impressão 3d está
fazendo uma revolução no nosso mundo a
fazer uma revolução do design vai
acontecer está acontecendo com o design
a mesma revolução que aconteceu com a
indústria da música existe uma nova
lógica na maneira de produção
distribuição comercialização desses
desses objetos com essa foi a primeira
experiência na segunda experiência que
já vai aparecer no vídeo a gente fez a
gente durante um fim de semana durante
dois dias no sábado e domingo em são
paulo
a gente convidou várias pessoas é abril
para a comunidade para aqueles narrassem
as suas histórias de amor agente coletou
55 histórias em dois dias e foi um
momento muito emocionante porque foi
muito bonito ver que o design pode
emocionar as pessoas no sentido de que
muita gente chorou isso foi uma grande
surpresa então quando as pessoas
entravam nessa sala isolada na galeria a
gente vestiu sensores nelas ea gente
explicar como funciona a experiência
saía da sala ficava ali sozinha com a
história dela narrando a grande história
de amor da vida dela
a gente colocou um doppler que é um
sensor que mede batimento cardíaco então
quando as pessoas entravam na na na
galeria você conseguia ouvir o batimento
cardíaco da pessoa em tempo real em
vários alto falantes que tinham nessa
galeria então você tava lá tu tu tu tu
repente ficava tu tu tu tu tu tu e você
visualizavam uma parede esses sensores
funcionando e você sentia que tinha uma
coisa acontecendo ali a pessoa sair se
debulhando assim sair chorando foi uma
foi uma surpresa teve o último casal
dentro dessa dessa experiência que eles
ficaram esperando ele quase cinco horas
para fazer experiência e filó é só
começo olha ligados estão esperando aqui
tanto tantas horas enquanto pouco a
história de vocês é um casal que está
aqui e ela me contou que eles são os
primeiros namorados
estão casados há mais de 40 anos as
filhas as três filhas estavam na galeria
nesse dia pra assistir à performance que
eles vão fazer
então a gente ficou tocado com aquela
história aparecendo nos momentos da peça
dessa performance a gente fez na galeria
dessa coleta de histórias e o que a
gente vê gente alterou a programação no
último momento que a gente ficou muito
tocado com essa história que a gente
colocou o casal na sala ele narrou para
ela o amor que ele tinha por ela olhando
pra ela e ela narrou para ele o amor que
ela tinha olhando pra ele e aí a gente
programou de uma maneira que gerasse uma
única mandala porque eles saíram estava
assim todo mundo chorando a filha
chorando casal chorando a galeria
inteira chorando todo mundo se abraçou
foi foi lindo saber que na verdade isso
é design e design pode emocionar
eles gostaram tanto da experiência que
eles resolveram tatuar o resultado no
corpo deles é bom que a gente gerou na
experiência nessa segunda experiência a
gente criou mandá-las impressas em 3d o
que é lindo como eu disse é que cada
mandala é única as regras do jogo são as
mesmas mas o resultado é único porque
cada sentimento é unificado história
única então quando se analisa a 50
mandalas mão do lado da outra incrível
resultado a gente faz parte de uma
geração que quer cada vez mais interagir
a gente não aceita mais informação do
jeito que ela vem pra gente a gente quer
interagir com esse conteúdo
se a gente volta alguns séculos lá pra
trás
é a gente consegue com uma certa clareza
distinguir é a cultura que vinha da
elite da nobreza da cultura que vem do
povo a cultura popular
quando tem a explosão dos meios técnicos
industriais né quando se desenvolve a
imprensa jornal rádio depois cinema
televisão tenho que a gente conhece como
cultura de massa
nenhuma das grandes características é
que essa cultura produzida por poucas
pessoas é que contam que fazem a
informação e consumida pela grande
maioria
então num programa de rádio é meia dúzia
de pessoas produzem no rádio e várias
pessoas sentavam em volta para ouvir o
rádio às seis da tarde aquele programa
aquela novela no rádio
com o surgimento do computador além dos
anos 90 a internet nos anos 2000 esse
quadro completamente invertido na gente
também quer produzir conteúdo
a gente também quer pôr a mão na massa
editar esse conteúdo e essa é a grande
característica da era digital essa hora
que a gente que a gente vive
é como se de repente todos os
equipamentos que a gente tem em casa
fala assim a mesma língua a linguagem do
beach o 0 1 0 0 1 e tudo começa a se
comunicar e as coisas começam a ficar
mais democráticas e um pouco mais fácil
de serem de dados com essa tecnologia ea
tecnologia passa por todas as camadas
aqui a gente tem algumas imagens da
experiência do love então vasos gerados
pelas histórias essas são as mandalas e
aqui quando a gente compara uma ou outra
a gente pode ver a diferença entre elas
o que eu acho interessante é que esse
projeto ele fala de uma coisa que eu
vejo muito sentido neste momento que o
mundo tá falado sustentabilidade não é
só falar de materiais
eu acredito que quando a gente consegue
criar objetos espaços arquiteturas
cidades carregando esses projetos de
carga emocional né trazendo o usuário
trazendo o cliente para essa produção
para esse processo de design
a gente cria um link nenhum vínculo que
ainda leve o que é inseparável entre o
produto e entre o usuário o que a gente
pode chamar de sustentabilidade afetiva
imagina você pode criar uma cadeira a
partir das emoções né do amor que tem
pelo seu filho
das lembranças do teu casamento ou das
lembranças de um amigo querido que já
faleceu com certeza o ciclo de vida
dessa cadeira vai ser muito mais longo
porque não interessa mas se tá na moda
se é bonito ou feio você automaticamente
tem uma história você tem uma feição com
aquele objeto não faz mais sentido criar
produtos o design está em crise assim
como todas as disciplinas que estimulam
o consumo é por isso que tem caído minha
filha recentemente que faz muito mais
sentido criar interfaces criar sistemas
onde a gente pode convidar o usuário
para participar desse processo de
criação é fazer um processo de co design
e design aberto design compartilhado com
autoria seja o nome que a gente quiser
mas quando você coloca o usuário lá
o resultado é muito mais rico é muito
mais interessante e automaticamente você
criam um vínculo de afeição
eu queria finalizar a amiga minha a
minha fala em 2000
- primeiro existe uma coisa muito séria
pra gente lidar neste momento em que a
questão da inclusão digital
se a gente não tiver programas sérios de
política de inclusão digital políticas
públicas de inclusão digital o abismo
entre ricos e pobres a ser cada vez
maior na cultura digital os makes os
editores produtores de conteúdo têm que
passar por todas as camadas sociais e
precisam acontecer de modo sério de modo
organizado com políticas públicas
o abismo entre ricos e pobres vai ser de
cada vez maior ea outra coisa é eu acho
fascinante que está nas nossas mãos da
nossa geração de todo mundo que está
aqui trabalhar com esses bichos
trabalhar com essas tecnologias elas
estão ao alcance de todo mundo eu acho
que o único sentido e um grande sentido
de trabalhar com esses bichos com essas
tecnologias é que a gente trabalha com
ela de maneira orgânica eu não consigo
imaginar o futuro minimalista frio
associado àquele futuro que às vezes a
gente imagina
eu acho que o futuro é muito mais surge
muito mais cheio de memória muito mais
cheio de identidade personalidade e
trabalhar com os beats para nos tornamos
seres humanos melhores para nos
tornarmos uma sociedade melhor e se só
pode ser o único sentido de trabalhar
com essas tecnologias digitais resolver
problemas e aí sim esse é o grande papel
do design resolver problemas
obrigado